[Music]
what any of you guys yes ever be so
petty to the point where you would burn
a million dollars in cash just to not
give it to your ex never give it to so
either I am able to hold on to a million
dollars or I burn it no no you hold a
you she will get you get have heard of
it yeah
but what I burn it she gets none of it
well yes I would burn all of it yeah can
i watch it's okay so now consider that
you have children oh dude she's a real
[ __ ] now if we're getting a divorce and
we have kids she's even bigger [ __ ]
ever said you gotta burn the water you
gotta burn the money in front of the kid
- see this is what mommy's making look
what Mommy made your daddy do that's
really like this could have been your
braces mommy just cost you your braces
that's a good life jeez
no I would not do that yeah because uh
this guy is 55 year old man named Bruce
from Canada Bruce he's a businessman and
it failed mayoral candidate and I
couldn't make mayor huh yeah must be
burning that million dollars she so he
withdrew 1 million and he claims that he
burned the money in two bonfires one
with 743 thousand dollars in September
and then 296,000 relief money come on
were we talking about he hid the cash
that's what the judge is assuming he's
like because this man had no proof no
witnesses off like nothing to show that
he actually burned no I promise I'm so
petty I'm so mad I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I burned it or I'm sorry hey I'm
sorry I'm sorry eight right and so which
is the boot
what is it the boot I'm sorry what is
this about Tommy
you got a comedian oh my I know
take out the trash ah yeah yeah that's
Canadian piss off the toilet seat close
the drawers
oh yeah so he also defied a court order
which was to not sell his properties and
he ended up selling some of his assets
to his former accountant it's trash yeah
and so he further defied the courts to
pay $300,000 as a security I respect him
for not trying to give his ex-wife any
money though it's making every attempt
possible
yeah he's got kids exactly the kids is
just like the kids would have been
benefiting from this money or he can
give it straight to them yeah how about
that so this is what so they have this
like dialogue a conversation and it's so
big here he didn't sell the house that
the kids are living in right okay I'll
be I'll be the I'll be the guy okay so
then the judge says so where's the money
now I destroyed it you've lost me what
do you mean mm oh and then so then he
ends up rambling about a relationship
with the daughter and then the judge
says can I back you up a bit when you
say you destroyed it what do you mean I
burnt it okay Birds it okay to the tune
of how much in total about a million and
$39,000 and then he later said that he
burned a million fifty thousand in all
and then he said the judge says how does
destroying over a million dollars
advance your child's best interest and
then oh yeah that's a good question that
you didn't film the bonfires he had no
witnesses you never recorded in any
fashion so then the judge says you
understand that's hard to believe yes I
do
hey you should have took a picture yes
something something but here no he
shouldn't have cuz he hid it yeah
exactly
or at least he could have like burned
some paper made it seem like
something well yeah so he says I it's
something he wouldn't normally do he's
not a person that's extremely mystery
allistic little goes a long way and he's
always been frugal and that's why his
business has lasted for thirty-one years
but the judge is still like you know
what you're full of [ __ ] you're gonna
have a 30-day term in the jail so beyond
for 30 days and he says so he ended up
imposing a $2,000 per day fine to be
paid directly to his ex-wife so that's
fourteen thousand dollars a week [ __ ]
and so he's just pretty much saying like
dude you might as well [ __ ] cough up
the money or you're gonna have to be
paying all these fines either way you're
not gonna end up with the money you
thought you could get away with so no 14
G's a week of so much money that's a lot
of money but what if he's like but I
really burnt it go to the burn site yes
sir they ended up saying that um you
know for a man who's claiming to have
zero income there are documents that
show that he has around nine thousand
dollars of expenses and months damn this
guy's trash trash why the trash trash
cuz he just lies is a big liar and he's
so [ __ ] he's off the books man but
what if he doesn't what if he wants to
give the money to the kids cuz like so
what I'm hearing is this he's not
selling the house at the kids rent he's
selling his assets right so as the
others other stuff the money all the
other stuff he doesn't he just wants to
keep that to the side and he wants to
funnel it to the kids the way he wants
that without passing it through the wife
well if that was the case I mean just
[ __ ] do the right thing split it in
half and see if your own money and give
that [ __ ] to the kid nobody courts are
taking all of it exactly the judge is
saying that the remaining assets and
anything else he has in his possession
it's gonna go to her that's why it was
like [ __ ] up burn it all
gyah what if there's like there's a good
place to go that you want to go to you
can't wait to get there but on the way
there's a shitty bumpy [ __ ] road
right that's the wife so he's trying to
get oh you're trying to take off roads
and go around so he can get to the dope
place and give us and give
I get it but I mean I guess I'm just not
a petty person no cuz she's the broad
right so so you're being shitty in there
yeah let me ask you a question
Jimmy let's say you made five times more
money than me and you know if we get a
divorce
Tiger staying with me that's the way
that's the way the law works in this
world as long as in California they like
the man yes would you would you be like
okay cool let me give half of my money
to this loser ass [ __ ] that's
gonna be a taker and you know this
[ __ ] gonna buy a boat with it
yeah and you know I've been searching
the bones I got boat catalogs all over
the place it's not even gonna go to
Tiger boots or would you go okay [ __ ]
this guy I'm gonna figure out my own way
to give the money directly had attacked
it through some [ __ ] his own personal IV
and not through this loser that wants to
buy boats cuz everytime I see money at
all my damn boats and then it'll be like
judge you see he bought a [ __ ] boat he
doesn't know how to take care of this
child give the kid to me big boat for me
the small boat for time you know what
probably happen is that your boat will
get season sold what would you do would
you would you be like [ __ ] it all I'll
give it this blues okay well when you
paint it that way of course I'm not
gonna give it to the [ __ ] loser but I
guess is that called being petty or is
that called take care of my kid I'm just
saying like most of the a lot it's
called taking care of my [ __ ] cub but
then I've been saying a lot of the laws
and the rules they favor the woman
because I mean it's common sense and her
statistics that back that seem gold
family homes and mom's usually are a
little bit more successful but I'm just
rying to flip it a little bit see the
other way and it's you but if he's
burning the money right then that's him
trying to get out of give her any money
right yep so it's like I feel like if
they have kids you know the idea is that
he's giving her money to help take care
of the kids you know I'm saying exactly
it's it's not so she can spend it unless
crazy
so done they will run off to another
country just to get away from child
support because they think all the
money's going to the woman hey some
dudes are pretty sick about child
support my dad was sick about it
sure so my dad always paid them off
never know what do you got [ __ ] maybe
eight single dads my dad was pretty sick
with the he always paid on time but he
didn't want to rub it in my mom's face
all the time but he never complained or
anything great that's why y'all need a
good Asian man not my dad stereotype
that [ __ ] was asked for only 200
bucks a month and he's like a good man
like Joe's dad jobs more payments since
[ __ ] I don't know 1999 or some [ __ ]
Oh Dan that came back to you real fast
Japanese men don't camp Japanese men are
supposed to be really good yeah no way I
heard what happened to you [ __ ] know
he pursued music completely opposite
just generalize everybody it's weird
angry you with the ratchet boys I like I
like angry raspy voice like idiots and
they say all men Steven I know you're
not a me Andrus after all I'm not a what
is it Andrus what Sonny and Reyes like
you're anti Neanderthals I gotta make
some you're fine you're from its me and
you're miss Sandra yes I get it it
sounds absurd it should just be man
hater what are they gonna say that all
right we all know what a man's a
misogynist for woman hater right right
but sense it's all so confusing yeah cuz
you're like oh I like massages right
misogynist in your life yeah yeah down
you're a misogynist damn can you hook me
up bro
come on do we have any misogynists like
we look at strong misogynist though like
I don't like the soft one yeah that's
what we're looking for
you need a work but anyway I think yeah
this whole thing is pretty crazy and it
makes me wonder too like what kind of
marriage that they have who you are is
the wrong for children would you say
probably a really nice marriage but
harmoniously yeah there's how to do it
out of circumstances yeah I mean
obviously the guy should be made to pay
the money right but you know there are
cases of people having to divorce or
like having to like remarry and [ __ ] for
citizenship like people that are married
here by law overseas not by US law or
whatever and then like that whole daca
[ __ ] and everything is happening right
so like and if they can't get their
citizenship but they've been here for a
while it's like how the [ __ ] do they
stay here and what they end up doing is
they'll divorce and they'll marry like
yeah hmm so they can stay here but
that's but for them it's it's weird
because some people are like bye honor
they don't want to do that because it
goes against her like Christian faith or
whatever but then there's the other part
where it's like yeah well then they want
to stay in America yeah which one do you
love more your husband or America oh
well they don't got a [ __ ] the other
person I saw it's all legal it's all
legal paperwork you more than America I
think really pushed in a corner yet so
you don't know yeah I don't know yet
yeah we don't know what we talking about
Auburn million dollars thank you he
looks like you guys the baller you don't
even look like a please he looks like
just paint fish now he looks like he
gives you terrible financial advice on
TV yeah welcome his eyebrows in his hair
out him in this election what I come as
I brothers hair in the same glow he's
like sell your Tesla stock it's gonna be
worthless oh my god worthless I tell you
yeah jump
[Music]